retirer vinsky Poutine vient de
finaliser l'annexion de légal un de ces
quatre régions à savoir louer entre
donye scarson et zapporja il a pris la
parole il espère que la situation dans
ces régions va se stabiliser et
l'affirme même avoir le plus grand
respect pour le peuple
ukrainien il joue à quoi
dont il a dit pendant longtemps que ce
peuple n'existait pas puisqu'il était un
avatar une version du peuple russe et
que l'entité
ukrainienne était quelque chose de
complètement artificiel créé par l'Union
soviétique et par un certain nombre de
combats et finalement d'affrontement
avec aussi avec les Russes de par le
passé puisque dans les années 1940 les
le nationalisme ukrainien était associé
enfin certains mouvements nationalistes
ukrainiens étaient associés au nazisme
bien donc pour lui si vous voulez
l'entité ukrainienne n'existe pas il est
bien obligé de reconnaître qu'il y a des
Ukrainiens ne serait-ce que parce qu'il
y a une une langue différente et que
pour Poutine la langue est un est une
frontière de séparation entre les
peuples mais pour le reste il change oui
effectivement de braquer est-ce que
qu'est-ce se perdit effectivement avec
ce genre d'affirmation d'insertion de
d'amadouer un peuple craignant qui
avance cette guerre était finalement
partagé par des par des oppositions
politiques assez normal assez
traditionnelles et qui se regroupent qui
se retrouvent entièrement soudés et
fédérés par cette guerre là encore on
est dans l'imaginaire
russe en tout cas non parus l'imaginaire
Poutine l'imaginaire qui consiste à
croire que quand on veut quelque chose
on l'obtient indépendamment du droit
international qui jusqu'à présent quand
même a réussi depuis la fin de la guerre
la deuxième guerre mondiale qui a réussi
à comment dirais-je à faciliter les
choses d'abord à donner la paix pendant
plus de 70 ans sur ce continent et à
faire en sorte aussi parle l'équilibre
de la terreur nucléaire que les choses
n'aillent pas trop mal et qu'on
n'empêche les déflagrations donc l'Union
soviétique de l'époque et même la Russie
en a profité mais pour Vladimir Poutine
ce droit international est lui aussi une
production de l'Occident donc sujet à
caution sujet à interrogation et même
susceptible d'être un jour supprimé
Poutine qui vient aussi de
signer des décrets rectificatifs
concernant la mobilisation partielle
parce qu'il n'avait pas le choix c'est
un peu le désordre oui d'une part par ce
que vous avez un certain nombre on l'a
vu alors manifestement c'est autour de
100000 personnes plus leur famille qui
fuient par les 9 points de sortie
possible entre le nord avec la Norvège
tout en haut et la Chine et la Mongolie
vers verlest ils sortent par là ça veut
dire aussi que ceux qui restent en tant
que réserviste n'ont pas forcément la
formation adéquate c'est ce que dit
Poutine lui-même il dit il faut corriger
le dire parce que certains ne sont pas
aguerris alors vous imaginez ce que ça
peut vouloir dire c'est à dire qu'on
envoie au front des soldats qui
éventuellement seront incapables de
réagir par eux-mêmes qui n'auront pas un
maniement des armes adéquat et qui donc
risque d'être plus un poids un boulet
pour l'armée russe qu'autre chose merci
beaucoup Gauthier pour